y'all think I care do I look like I give
a [ __ ] I am the coolest [ __ ] on
this planet do you think some little
kids spouting [ __ ] online it's gonna
make me quit [ __ ] you for even thinking
that for a second I'm gonna review your
painted little piece of [ __ ] videos and
that'll be it please don't be me I don't
know how long I can keep this facade up
let's watch the first video of the first
Hey
yeah we're here and we're gonna talk
about how PewDiePie how he sucks
[ __ ]
you can't even suck [ __ ] it's a
round object look at this how will I
suck it and girlfriend is dead what how
did you know how did you know you guys
are just [ __ ] like I bet PewDiePie
have like this hypnotizing thing and you
guys all got hypnotized and now you're
all [ __ ] in the gay army yeah that's
brilliant it's not true god damn it I am
not hypnotizing you I am not hypnotizing
anyway and especially not might see it
I must conserve my energy this hater is
not worth it we're the real deal
PewDiePie cringe make me want to kill
myself
why do you have so many subscribers pity
[ __ ] you give me some subscribers no
with the with the [ __ ] hours 8
what's goin on browse this escape for my
name amputee paw hey so psycho put on a
talk on this is becoming a meme now
track like a [ __ ] [ __ ] and hating
on PewDiePie because if that's the case
you win
hey guys Blackie Blackie kid Blackie kid
nine one seven seven year you don't even
know your old name dude what the [ __ ]
maybe next time water let's listen to
what he says just turn I'm just a turd I
am just a turd I'm just a turd who the
[ __ ] do you call a [ __ ] turd
I'll come here and turn up on your face
oh [ __ ] dare you call a turn my mom
called me a turd how dare you speak to
me like that [ __ ] you your turn your
turn you curly mate son of a [ __ ] I
will stab you haters oh my god it's
Malcolm one of my biggest general
enemies Malcolm let's return a long time
to figure out a response how can I
prepare for this a part of [ __ ]
absolute [ __ ] inferno that he's about
to place upon me Malcolm please spare me
haters odd sucks
thank my name Dubai haters are so mean
I don't know that's right
I agree pit fire haters are mean Malcolm
you make a great point
thank you finally for trusting me I
really appreciate you finally building a
little better trust oh that's real
creative that's yo ah my number-one
insecurity about being gay PewDiePie is
gay he
have never existed PewDiePie should kill
himself or quit YouTube
screw the broker me the bros are fat
and should also kill themselves brofist
more like gay fist professed mana gave
us the roasts I can't handle them no
told me that is fair yeah it is it
stopped what the [ __ ]
make up your goddamn mind dirt there
[ __ ] you playing me some some kind of
game I freaking don't want to see pretty
pie on my front page of my YouTube thing
every [ __ ] day I'm sick and tired of
it I think this guy is actually legit
hey hey Jesus Christ this guy's [ __ ]
blazing me dollars that's cute destroyed
I have been destroyed everything I
worked so hard to create
my YouTube channel
it's over I give up
roasting kid 19:07 this one pewdiepie
should kill himself pewdiepie he just
turn
all right listen up you [ __ ] haters I
don't care who you are I don't care what
your name is I don't care what your age
is if you're a beautifly hater I won't
come to your house and that was smash
your mom's ass sorry I will smash your
door in and I will eat up your pet and
that will pay you
I will fart on your daddy I will fart on
your pillow [ __ ] you do all the haters
you can go unsubscribe